beginning
I thought London was cool okay because I
had moved from Chicago to London to play
volleyball okay and what I thought was
cool was on my team I had a girl from
Germany a girl from England a girl from
America a girl from Spain okay and so
what I was thinking is wow I can be in
this city and I can talk to people that
have completely different views on
relationships wow and I have never been
in such a diverse area because here you
might meet someone from Alaska Chicago
California but how diverse is the
thought process really sure but Italy
and I don't know
um like I had a girl from Morocco on my
show wow yeah completely different holy
and so you'll notice I mean the majority
are British people but there's still a
good amount of people that come and a
lot of them are second Generations their
parents are like Nigerians well yeah of
course yeah of course yeah and so I just
thought it would be really interesting
to bring in these people to talk about
relationships okay
um it did switch a little bit to be more
ant titanism I would say yeah you're all
I remember early on it was every other
video I'm trying to convince my friend
I'm trying to talk her out of feminism
here's here's episode one yeah and that
was that was the light bulb was I had
one video and it was like I red pilled
my friend for the first time that's
right and what I realized is like as
women we have all these lies that we
like believe yes and we're just like fed
into and if you don't have strong men in
your life like I think we're very
um
like
I don't know the word but like
self-destructive yeah yeah sort of yes
yeah well modern women are the default
for modern women is self-destruction
yeah that's what it is well and even
even just like more liberal yeah like of
course because I think we're more kind
caring and like compassion like we're
it's called agreeable that's right and
and I think like it's out of a good
place like we want to help sure but I
think it leads to like Terror
and so it's like like we believe all
these like the pay Gap and like it's
like because we're like so I think it's
you know partially entitlement partially
empathetic you know right but
um and so I I realize there's all these
girls that I really like and they're
reasonable but they believe these things
that are so stupid yes and I could it
could have been me because if I take a
personality test it says I'm a die-hard
liberal really yeah that's why I like
because I'm very creative oh that's like
why do you why do you think a hippie
like why do we assume hippies are
liberals because they're creative open
to excuse yeah right they tend to be
more liberal we're like people at a
conservative tend to be type A so I've
always found that I get along better
with people that are more liberal so
yeah yeah yeah because you're like a
wolf in sheep's clothing yeah because
conservatives like tend to be more
boring when liberals are like ah let's
go you know
and which is you know it's um the trait
openness but and I was like I like these
girls but they believe this stupid stuff
I wonder if I showed them this video how
if it would change their view on the
world right and it really just started
to like my friend Jess yeah I took her
on the show and first she was arguing
that like trans people should be like
into sports and then like you got her a
couple months later she's like nah get
him out right you want your school
correct you want to get dunked on yeah
like because I was explaining to her I'm
like I know where I know it's out of
like she's such a nice person it's out
of like a place of being empathetic like
you don't want to exclude anybody right
you realize this will be the end of our
sport yes like you're they're going to
start taking titles and like how would
you feel if you were playing behind
someone without for with how hard we
work and like when you put put it like
that it's like we're not doing it to
exclude them it's just because we we
want a right to our sport right right
and it's funny because a lot of a lot of
um a lot of women who play sports were
pro-transformer I'll just say that until
people like Leah Thomas came along you
know the the swimmer from Penn State you
know
uh she used to be a he I'm trying to be
very careful here and he dominated of
course he did and then of course there
are also MMA fights there was one in I
forget what the girl's name is Fallon
Fox yes yes I gave some chicken
concussion beat her up for 45 seconds
like that's dangerous yeah it absolutely
is and again I don't a lot of times I
think like I would see people like
coming at like getting getting somewhat
aggressive towards women and like no I
don't wanna because a lot of times the
girls kind of deserve it yeah like you
know they're being rude but I just know
how to like talk to girls to kind of
like calm them down a little bit that
that listen this is this is what
separates you from everybody else that's
literally what it is you have an
incredible you have a you have an
incredible sense of reading the room but
you're very you're very good at
de-escalating while also disagreeing and
it's so funny because there are so many
gotcha moments on your podcast where
what you say is true but the way you
it's coming from an Other Woman and
you're never aggressive unless I'm a guy
when I'm on fresh and fit I'm telling
these [ __ ] your captain your captain
you're full of [ __ ] [ __ ] you blah blah
blah blah and you know of course a lot
of that is a lot of that is a little
more theatrical than it should be but
most of the time it really is it really
is because I feel that way and sometimes
that just doesn't go over well yeah but
if one of ours if one of ours is is is
sitting right here oh she's the host and
she's going to agree blah blah blah blah
it's almost like they don't see you
coming they're like whoa wait a minute
this girl is not on our side what the
hell is going on and and I really don't
blame you guys for like coming up that
way because a lot of times like they
deserve it they deserve it all right
yeah but it's just like I don't know I
always try to like calm them down and
it's crazy
um I've I've never kicked anyone off the
show in six months which is weird never
um wow I won have you come close yes yes
I have never actually we we would get
him to like okay okay oh my God I would
love to do it I would love to see you
kick somebody off the show oh it would
take a lot it would yeah well I'll tell
you what if if you were if you were
privy to the same kinds let's compare
let's compare your
um let's compare your guest pool to the
fresh and fit guest pool I wish I had
that guest pool really oh I wish you sat
on the panel with these girls have you
not yeah yeah you really listen I don't
listen man I don't know how Myron does
it they make great TV they do they make
I I I think um I think like I think a
battle of ideas like is better sure sure
if I could oh God I wish they do a great
job recruiting they do a very good job
they actually recruit themselves to be
honest with you but you still get that's
you still get that same kind of
disagreement on your show without the
Miami Lottery crazy stuff you you
understand what I mean or do What's the
diff well let's talk about this what's
the difference between your uh between
you know the people that you have the
have to pick from and fresh and fit like
are they better worse I mean what are
some differences that you've noticed
um I mean we have less girls that have
only fans definitely yeah
the fresh and fit podcast they all have
only fans yeah I could probably count
how many girls actually had only that I
know of I don't know you know exactly
yeah but like we're plugging it on the
show like I can't less than five maybe
wow
um I think fresh and fit had five on
yesterday yeah I don't I don't know
in the UK than it is in the United
States the girls are a little different
in the UK really how so no okay they're
not they do that they the same but I
would say like they're a little bit like
like more secret do you know what I'm
saying yeah yeah they're not as they're
not as upfront about it yeah yeah that's
how like they they kind of dress a
little bit more classy I would say that
like and partially it's a little colder
so yes oh the weather [ __ ] sucks
there dude oh my God I don't know how
you do it yeah
um but I don't know I would say
especially early on like it was a lot of
athletes okay but the mindset is still I
was just gonna that was my next question
it's still there I would just say it's
less extreme because I think most people
are more in the middle or as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible